what is going on guys welcome to the
fourth geographical plotting within
python tutorial with a base map where we
left off we were making well we I showed
you guys that cool blue marble and stuff
but we're not actually going to be using
that someone do that the other things
that we're going to change I'll keep
this with this and actually that's scary
to try rivers we don't need to be
drawing rivers and then we'll do that so
again kind of like what I was saying
before this is you're coming from
matplotlib this is kind of like how we
set up or subplot like the parameters
that we want it to take as we do this so
like I was saying I think probably be in
our best interest to focus on like one
area so we can start plotting and seeing
it really well so I'm going to go ahead
and have us focus in on the United
States so the first thing that we want
to do is change up our coordinates a
little bit so really the lower-left
coordinate we really want that to be
more like 20 upper right corner lat will
do 50 lower left corner longitude
negative 130 and upper right corner will
be a negative 60
save that run it let's make sure we did
that right yeah it looks good so now
this is what we've got we could kind of
trim this away a little bit but that's
okay we'll leave it like this for now
but you know as we plot in various
spaces we'll be able to see it better
so let's actually make a plot so like I
was saying before first of all the
things are flipped just to keep in mind
so again coordinates are typically given
latitude than longitude and really in
our scenario that's like giving us
coordinates for y comma X right it's
that's kind of the opposite of what we
want so you want to keep in mind that
and you also want to keep in mind that
north-south east-west so if you're
getting coordinates that have a
north-south east-west instead of
negative and positive values you want to
convert them I will say that a lot of
places are actually giving the
coordinates and you know positive and
negative so it's actually kind of nice
because I wasn't always like that and
there's still a lot of places and
sources that are going to have
with north-south-east-west but just keep
that in mind and just do like a switch
if you have a source from giving those
kinds of coordinates but then don't
forget at the end of the day that once
you have those coordinates you have to
flip flip the X&Y basically so keep that
in mind so let's say you have Houston
Texas so what we're going to want to
plot is a dot on Houston Texas and the
latitude and longitude of Houston Texas
is basically twenty nine point seven six
and negative ninety five point three six
I'll just keep it short for now so the
next thing you need to do though you
can't just like plot that you have to
kind of convert it so what we're going
to do is not only we're going to convert
it to the base map we're going to also
like what a format that base maps going
on it's kind of like when you want to do
stuff with numpy you have to first
convert it like an array to an umpire
right so you need to put it in a format
that this base map will understand so
because if you if you saw I was we were
hovering over base map it didn't give us
latitude and longitude like in the
corner there so you can't just do this
quite yet but we'll get there so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
say X comma Y so x and y equals m and
that is referencing you know your base
map projection all this stuff and then
we want to do long lat right X is your
longitude why is your latitude so XY
just can I keep beating that in your
head now all you have to do is m dot
plot XY and then here we're going to
make a red dye and it's just going to be
a little dot and we better just change
this we'll call this geo plotting so
that's what we're doing now right we are
geo plotting so render that and I can't
see it in YouTube but there is a little
minuscule dot over Houston and if you're
following us then you should have that
dot as well the other thing we can do we
could say like red we can do this I'll
see if this works
for us there we go made a little bit
bigger instead of a dot we use this like
zero marker so anyway you can do that
now what if we like you know maybe want
to make another plot or something
eventually you can just make a big array
out of this like you would just instead
probably do lat equals an array lon
equals an array of equal lengths
basically and do that but just just for
kicks
will do flat lon equals and for Boulder
Colorado
forty point one two and then the one
twos negative one oh four point two four
then we're going to say XY equals M
lonely and then n dot plot y and again
we'll just you will plot this one green
save that run it and now you can see
that we've got this red dot and a green
dot there the over Boulder over Houston
pretty cool now that's cool but there
are obviously a few small changes that
we might want to make first of all maybe
we're only plotting and dealing with
major cities well in that case these
dots are way too small right no matter
how much you zoom that's how big the dot
is so maybe you want to have that dot a
little bigger and then but what if what
if you're plotting every city in the
world and you've got dots like this and
they run over each other that kind of
stuff so I'm going to show you guys in
the next tutorial how we can deal with
that with some alpha and also how we can
change the size and that'll probably
cover it in the next video and that
should be enough for you guys to get
started at least with geographical
plotting I'm not too sure what else you
might want to do you know some people
want to plot like wind bands and all
these kind of stuff
so there's a obviously a lot of reasons
you might do geographical plotting but
this will at least get you started so
anyway stay tuned in the next video as
always thanks for watching